so yesterday was Memorial Day here in
the United States Donald Trump was at a
wreath-laying ceremony and I got a ton
of emails and a bunch of articles I read
arguing that Donald Trump was visibly
struggling to stand at a Memorial Day
event and that there is this sort of
weird way in which Trump seems to be off
balance and regularly recalibrating his
balance so I'm not gonna spend a ton of
time on this if you know my show you
know we've covered Trump's strange
behavior whose sources we've never yet
determined we've not yet determined and
I'm going to talk about that a little
bit let's let's first look at the videos
and then I'll tell you what I think
here's one video during a rendition
yesterday of the national anthem and
Donald Trump does seem unable to just
stand up straight his whole whole upper
torso is sort of rocking forward forward
and back as he's in a salute position
and it wasn't a windy day reports are
that wind was only four miles per hour
no one else is swaying in that way and
that was the source of some of the
concern here is another video from
yesterday in which Donald Trump walks up
to a wreath and is staring at it and
again he's kind of swaying in the wind
sort of swaying back and forth and he
does at moments seem like he's going in
the direction of falling over but his
balance system realizes it and
compensates by pulling him back so I
want to be like a hundred and ten
percent crystal clear this could be
something or it could be nothing and
we've sinned we've seen this type of
stuff since day one with Trump these
inner ear balance type issues can be
related to all sorts of different things
in earlier stages sometimes even before
other dementia symptoms develop starting
to have issues balancing when standing
or walking can suggest an increased
potential to develop Alzheimer's or
other types of dementia balance issues
can be related to medication side
effects people speculate that Trump
takes stimulants stimulants can
certainly affect your balance but they
can also simply affect
ability to sit still because you're
energized in this way that uppers
stimulants and amphetamines can can do
this could also be Trump's weird stance
I know some of you are aware that Trump
stands in a very weird way kind of
hinged forward at the at the hips um
that might make it difficult to stand
still there's speculation that Trump
stands that way because he wears lifts
in his shoes which sort of lean him
forward what we know is this is not new
what we know is it wasn't windy
yesterday Trump wasn't getting blown
around by wind so if you say to me do I
think something is up here big picture
you all know I think something's up and
I don't know if the video from yesterday
is part of it or if it's something new
or if it's nothing if you say do I
really care well I care if it's
something that's impacting Trump's
cognition because he's the President of
the United States whether or not
something like this explains Trump's
behaviors and actions Trump has failed
either way right
like the coronavirus response has been a
failed response whether or Trump has
dementia an inner ear issue is abusing
drugs or whatever the case may be it
could be ADHD right I mean if maybe
Trump can't stand still but does a good
job because he has ADHD and it's hard
for him to stand still who cares right
the point is he's not doing a good job
and he can't stand still and looks
unstable and looks confused and got off
of Air Force One and didn't recognize
his own limo in front of him and
wandered off until a Secret Service
agent brought him back holding him is
that why he's a bad president no he'd be
a terrible president no matter what the
explanation is does it aggravate the
lethality of this presidency yeah yeah
it probably does will we ever know
what's really going on here I don't know
I you know inside the Reagan White House
they knew while he was president that he
was starting to show signs and symptoms
of Alzheimer's it was learned sort of
officially publicly later only in
retrospect did people start
figuring out that it was not something
that happened only after he was out of
office he was experiencing symptoms
while he was in office my instinct is we
probably would not get anything
definitive about Trump while he is in
office it is yet another reason to get
him out in November meaning he would
leave in January rather than giving him
another four years hopefully someday we
do know exactly what it is that is going
on okay I want to now do a little bit of
a deep dive into a recent poll this is
an utterly devastating poll for Donald
Trump with the normal caveats it's May
things can change very quickly between
now and November look at how quickly
they changed for Joe Biden within 72
hours after the South Carolina primary
now there is a Fox News poll that says
Trump is losing forty eight to forty two
Joe Biden right now I know some of you
will say David a Fox News poll what the
hell are you doing that that's crazy
Fox News why do we care Fox News polling
is its own enterprise they are well
ranked as far as polling goes and they
were pretty accurate back in 2016
538 ranks two different Fox News polling
partnerships as in either a - or a /b so
Fox News polling is actually pretty
reliable it's very different than what
you hear on their airwaves on the
question of Trump versus Biden
nationally Joe Biden has an eight-point
lead forty eight to forty Trump is
winning among men and Trump is winning
among whites losing a ton of other
important split so Trump is losing women
to Joe Biden Trump is losing black and
Hispanic voters Trump is losing all
non-white voters Trump is losing people
under 45 Trump is losing people over 45
Trump is losing people earning under
$50,000 a year and people earning more
than $50,000 a year but there's
something really interesting when you
look at some of the other splits
according to this poll four percent of
Democrats plan to vote for Trump and
eight percent of Republicans plan to
vote for Biden understand that if 2016
essentially holds with the one change of
four percent of Democrats abandoned the
Democratic Party and
Trump 8% of Republicans abandoned Trump
and vote for Joe Biden that's all you
need to flip a bunch of states I'll give
you just one example we're gonna use
Hillary and Trump 2016 numbers to think
about this
so in Wisconsin in 2016 Hillary Clinton
lost by just under twenty three thousand
votes each candidate got about 1.4
million votes Trump just over 1.4
million Clinton just under 1.3 million
so this is very simple math you take 4%
of Hillary's votes from 2016 and
assigned them to Trump you take 8% of
trumps votes and imagine that they went
to Hillary or you know potentially they
would go to Joe Biden that alone would
have given Hillary Clinton a 91,000 vote
victory in Wisconsin instead of a loss
so that is just one state it is just one
example but understand this idea that we
basically maintain 2016 if four percent
of Democrats switch and eight percent of
Republicans switch Trump loses Trump
loses now I want to make it again
I know people said David what a you know
these disclaimers maybe aren't necessary
they are necessary right now we have a
long way to go this is a snapshot of
right now if the perception of the
economy improves by November if the
perception of how things are going with
coronavirus improves by November we may
very very quickly see this these numbers
reverse dramatically we must all vote we
must all get out the vote etc lastly
just one other thing on issues Trump is
always in these polls strongest on the
economy Trump is still stronger than
Biden on the economy in this latest Fox
News poll but it's by a far narrower
margin than we've seen throughout
Trump's presidency lastly on China Trump
in great part ran not just on all fix
the economy even though the economy was
doing quite well when Trump was running
Trump ran on I know how to deal with
China I know how to deal with trade
right now Joe Biden is polling as more
trustworthy on China that is one of
Trump's primary issue
alongside this amorphous
all-encompassing economic issues that he
tends to do well on those issue based
numbers are very very important let me
know what you think make sure you are
subscribed to the daily David Pakman
show audio podcasts get it on iTunes
stitcher or any podcast app that you
prefer we'll be back after this with
some interesting videos to play for you
some interesting tweets and much more so
Twitter for the first time has flagged
Trump tweets as possibly misleading
essentially a flag they've established a
signal fake news and Donald Trump has
absolutely lost his mind and is talking
even about shutting down social media
platforms that do this now I told you
yesterday that Twitter they kind of have
special rules for politicians and
prominent figures where normally for
example you would not be allowed to
accuse random people of murder on
Twitter and SiC your followers on them
but Donald Trump did that to Joe
Scarborough and Twitter allows it
because they say when Trump does it it
in and of itself is newsworthy and thus
it should be allowed to stay because it
is the a catalyst for much reporting
it's newsworthy in in and of itself
because of the person who is doing it
so yesterday Donald Trump sent out two
tweets with absolute lies about
vote-by-mail and Twitter flagged them
both and provided fact-checking
and Donald Trump lost his you-know-what
and this is a technique that Twitter put
in place similar to one that Facebook
has when fake news articles are posted
and this is infuriating to Trump let's
check out the claims and then the truth
and this is so important not just
because good for Twitter for
fact-checking the president but it's
important because vote-by-mail is again
becoming sort of like the new battle
line in the upcoming 20/20 election
Donald Trump said there is no way zero
that mail-in ballots will be anything
less than substantially fraudulent mail
boxes will be robbed ballots will be
forged and even illegally printed out
and fraudulently signed the government
of California the Governor of California
is sending ballots
to millions of people anyone living in
the state no matter who they are or how
they got there will get one that will be
followed up with professionals telling
all of these people many of whom have
never even thought of voting before how
and for whom to vote this will be a
rigged election no way now as you can
see if you're looking at this there's a
flag there with an exclamation point
that says get the facts about mail-in
ballots sort of an instant fact check
which tells you if you click it that
Donald Trump is falsely claiming that
mail-in ballots would lead to a rigged
election that's not true there's no
evidence that mail-in ballots are linked
to voter fraud Trump falsely claims
California is going to send mail-in
ballots to anyone no matter how they got
there implying undocumented immigrants
would get ballots in fact not only is
that not true only registered voters
would receive ballots if you live in
California but are not registered to
vote you won't get a ballot at all five
states have already voted entirely by
mail all states offer some kind of
absentee voting according to NBC News
also part of the fact check
now the right-wingers who love to cry
about anti conservative discrimination
on Twitter and Facebook
they are slamming Twitter for this but
this is exactly what Twitter needs to be
doing CNN and MSNBC and Fox News should
be doing it during Trump and Caylee
maghen Annie's press briefings I've
talked about responsible platforming
instant fact-checking
this is how Donald Trump's tweets should
also be handled now the amazing thing is
when Twitter did this Trump tweeted an
apology for spreading fake news Trump
deleted his tweets and he thanked
Twitter for correcting him no obviously
that's not true
Trump absolutely lost it when Twitter
did this attacking them and CNN and the
Washington Post for some reason tweeting
quote Twitter is now interfering in the
2020 presidential election they are
saying my statement on mail-in ballots
which will lead to massive corruption
and fraud is incorrect based on
fact-checking
by fake News CNN and the Amazon
Washington Post adding that quote
Twitter is completely stifling
free speech and I as president will not
allow it to happen then Trump actually
tweeting about shutting platforms down
tweeting quote Republicans feel that
social media platforms totally silence
conservatives voices we will strongly
regulate or close them down before we
can ever allow this to happen
we saw what they attempted to do and
failed in 2016 we can't let a more
sophisticated version of that happen
again
just like we can't let large-scale
mail-in ballots take root in our country
it would be a free-for-all on cheating
forgery and the theft of ballots whoever
cheated the most would win
likewise social media clean up your act
now extremely dangerous dystopian
totalitarian language from the president
we cannot relent on this I implore
Twitter not to relent
I implore other platforms and media
outlets on TV to do the exact same thing
instant fact-checking of Donald Trump
what would be amazing would be if
Twitter fact-checked
Trump's attack on Twitter right like is
interference in the elections inclusive
of just fact-checking the president no
that's a lie our Trump's claims about
massive corruption and fraud incorrect
yes those are not true is fact-checking
by CNN incorrect no Trump is wrong now
it should be mentioned this is the
president saying Twitter doing fact
checks has something to do with the
Constitution's First Amendment Trump is
accusing Twitter of violating his First
Amendment rights can you imagine can you
imagine a president this incompetent
when it comes to the basics of what the
First Amendment is Twitter has the same
First Amendment right to decide which
falsehoods and lies they will allow to
spread on their private platform just
like other private businesses have the
ability and right to do this was a big
topic when I was on with Joe Rogan on
Friday
what should the limits be here whose
extend how far when it comes to what
Twitter can be compelled to do versus
what Twitter is allowed to do as an
organization that has terms and
conditions Trump is going to put huge
pressure on Twitter and other platforms
it is very clear this is part of the
culture war this is part of the battle
lines now I want this to escalate
Twitter actually could get Trump to
completely lose his mind if they keep up
the fact checking with his of his tweets
with accurate information good for
Twitter I'm not endorsing or criticizing
anything else about Twitter other than
this is the right thing to do they
should keep doing it look at how
instantly triggered Donald Trump was
will follow what will certainly be a
wild next 24 to 48 hours as the fallout
from this continues keep an eye out one
other warning and then I want to move on
keep an eye out for how people around
from are going to create specious
special pleadings to argue that Twitter
should be banned from doing this
essentially we'll follow up on that when
it happens let's give it time to develop
today we will reach the unconscionable
tragic milestone of 100,000 dead
americans from coronavirus there that is
a number we may have already reached by
the time you listen to today's show or
watched today's program and that is a
number that we have reached with
widespread now allegations of data
suppression in a number of different
states which I will discuss with you on
tomorrow's program but it we've already
passed 100,000 is the point whether we
officially get there today or yesterday
or tomorrow we actually have passed that
number
some time ago due to the believed
suppression and a mischaracterization of
some deaths and as this is going on the
President of the United States has been
tweeting allegations that a TV host
murdered someone without any evidence
and Donald Trump also tweeted or
retweeted a tweet calling Hillary
Clinton a skank but today I want to talk
about these murder smears that Donald
Trump has been making against MSNBC's
Joe Scarborough Donald Trump tweeting
quote
a lot of interest in this story about
psycho Joe Scarborough so a young
marathon runner just happened to faint
in his office hit her head on his desk
and died I would think that there is a
lot more to this story than that an
affair and what about the so-called
investigator Reid story
Trump also tweeted a blow to her head
body found under his desk left Congress
suddenly big topic of discussion in
Florida and he's a nut job with bad
ratings
keep digging use forensic geniuses so
what this all relates to is a Joe
Scarborough staffer that died in 2001
was a 28 year old woman Loree class
Udhas and conspiracy theories started
about her death pretty quickly down in
Florida and this is 19 years ago Trump
is now reviving this and giving it
oxygen Media Mia merely because he is in
a media battle with Joe Scarborough
because he doesn't like joe
scarborough's coverage of donald trump
on MSNBC that's all that this is
but the president is accusing a media
host he does not like of murder even
many Republicans are disgusted by this
Illinois Republican Rep Adam Kinzinger
tweeted quote completely unfounded
conspiracy just stop stop spreading it
stop creating paranoia it will destroy
us Fox News bomb-thrower Brit Hume even
tweeting quote 30,000 retweets for this
discredited tale based on a three year
old post from some wingding web site
this is why even his critics should want
Trump to play a lot of golf because when
he does he's not tweeting crap like this
so the analysis here is 90% obvious and
I want to focus on the 10 percent that
maybe is less obvious of course in that
90 percent yes this is not normal yes
the world is laughing and crying and
pitying us yes
Trump accusing people of murder on
Twitter is an absolute
in total horror as 100,000 people have
died of coronavirus in the United States
with as many as 2/3 of those deaths
preventable with just a couple week
earlier call for national stay at home
orders the only remaining question is
why Trump is still allowed on Twitter
and I got a lot of emails over the
weekend from from you guys saying David
you know Trump is he's specifically
targeting someone with false allegations
with a conspiracy theory that person Joe
Scarborough is being bullied now Joe
Scarborough is getting death threats and
how is this how is Twitter allowing this
what you have to understand is Twitter
has very specific rules for what you can
and can't say but they have different
rules for famous people in politicians
and Twitter put out rules last year I
believe it was which I'm characterizing
it in the way I see it you can read the
full text of it if you want if a world
leader or a politician tweet something
that would normally violate their policy
like for example in this case Trump is
targeting an individual for mass
bullying like Trump did by saying Joe
Scarborough might have murdered someone
if it's Trump if they leave it up
because the mere fact that it's Trump
who said it makes it newsworthy in a way
where it's newsworthiness and the fact
that it will be reported on necessitates
leaving it up so that it can be properly
reported on is is sort of the gist to it
and I understand that but Twitter can
also say make the news elsewhere right
it's not what we want our community to
be used for making news about imagine
being the family of 20 then 28 year old
Lorie class Udhas you've been trying to
recover from an inconceivably traumatic
event that took place 19 years ago where
your 28 year old family member died and
in comes the President of the United
States retweeting a three year-old
conspiracy article from a nonsense
website all because he doesn't like joe
scarborough's coverage of him
this is an era listen the Trump era is
going to be an era
we're number one we should never forgive
the Trump administration nor the people
who voted to put him in power but as a
country hopefully at some point we fix
this atrocity hopefully it's in five
months it might not be until four years
and five months which would be tragic I
hope eventually the world is able to
forget the United States as a country
I'm not saying forgive the Trump voters
and I'm certainly not saying forgive
Trump in his administration but I hope I
hope that at some point the world will
forgive us as a country for this
absolute aberration that hopefully will
only last for years but may last eight
years if we don't take care of business
on November third okay Donald Trump's
press secretary Kaley mcenany visibly
and audibly failed to explain why Donald
Trump is accusing TV host joe
scarborough of murder on twitter during
a press briefing yesterday this was i
believe her shortest press briefing in a
long time I think it was 16 minutes only
she barely takes questions and often
just aborts when it gets a little bit
dicey and you have to see this to
believe it
so to catch you up yesterday I told you
that Donald Trump spent the weekend as
the United States coronavirus death toll
approached and has now surpassed 100,000
Trump spent the weekend not just golfing
but also retweeting that Hillary Clinton
is a skank and accusing MSNBC host joe
scarborough of murder i showed you these
tweets yesterday we'll go over them one
more time Trump tweeting quote a lot of
interest in this story about psycho Joe
Scarborough so a young marathon runner
just happened to faint in his office hit
her head on his desk and died I would
think there is a lot more to this story
than that an affair what about the
so-called investigator read story
referring to a three year old right wing
nut story Trump also tweeting a blow to
her head body found under his desk left
Congress suddenly big topic of
discussion in Florida he's a nut job
with bad ratings keep digging use
forensic geniuses
as I told you yesterday what this all
relates to is a Scarborough staffer that
tragically died in 2001 the woman was 28
year old Lori kiss loudest clipless
Udhas maybe better better pronounced and
of course Kaylee Mackin Annie was asked
about this and the nearly two minute
answer that she gives is bizarre it's a
combination of what about ISM
condescension incompetence and lies
let's look at it together and I
apologize for subjecting you to a little
more than 90 seconds of this but I think
it is important to understand the full
answer that she gave or not answer that
you gave accusing somebody of possible
murder the family is pleading with the
president to please stop doing well you
know I would note that the president
said this morning that this is not an
original Trump thought on and it is not
in fact 2003 on Don Imus show it was Don
Imus and Joe Scarborough that joked
about killing an intern joked and
laughed about it so that was I'm sure
pretty hurtful to Laurie's family and
Joe Scarborough himself brought this up
with Don Imus and Joe Scarborough
himself states and he's accusing
somebody of possibly murder this is
different he's he's not a private
citizen he's the president and Joe
Scarborough if we want to start talking
about false accusations we have quite a
few we can go through about mica
asserting time to you and saying this
morning as recently I believe it was
this morning or yesterday mica accused
the president of being responsible for a
hundred thousand deaths in this country
that's incredibly irresponsible they've
dragged his family through the mud
they've made false accusations that I
won't go through that I would not say
from this podium against the President
of the United States and they should be
held to account for their falsehoods Joe
Scarborough should be held to account
for saying people will die by taking
hydroxychloroquine never mind the
millions of Americans and people across
the world who take it for rheumatory
arthritis and other reasons there are
litany of false headlines like mica
spreading a false conspiracy theory this
exact sponsible for murder I would point
you back to Joe Scarborough who laughed
and joked about this item on Don Imus
this show it's Joe Scarborough that has
to answer these questions why is the
president doing this was the question
why is the president accusing someone of
murder and the family of the of the
victim is saying please stop Caylee Mac
and Annie's answer is Trump didn't come
up with the idea that Scarborough
murdered someone and Joe Scarborough and
Don Imus joked about murdering an intern
once now joking about murdering an
intern might be in bad taste but it had
nothing to do with this actual death to
say Trump is justified in tweeting that
maybe Joe Scarborough killed Laura
Kozlowski burrow and Don Imus joking
maybe in poor taste about killing an
intern secondly Joe Scarborough and Don
Imus were not the presidents of the
United States they weren't President of
the United States tweeting bogus death
accusations bogus killing allegations to
their eighty million followers which is
what Donald Trump is doing then she says
well joe scarborough's co-host mika
brzezinski once said things we believe
to be false about Donald Trump Mika
Brzezinski is not the president Donald
Trump is the president there is no
relevance or comparison now in terms of
hydroxychloroquine people have died from
taking it but again that has nothing to
do with Trump accusing people of murder
on Twitter we're a joke guys I hate to
say it but were a joke we have a
petulant incompetent child as the
president tweeting conspiratorial murder
allegations against the TV host that he
simply doesn't like the president is
accusing people of murder on Twitter the
press secretary is defending it by
saying well other people said things we
don't like that's the defense but we're
talking about the president she has
nothing to say in reality because there
is nothing to say she represents nothing
she is the spokeswoman for a madman and
she doesn't care how does she sleep at
night she claims to be some kind of
supposed Christian
that's probably a story for another day
but absolutely unconscionable what Trump
is doing how Kaley Magnani
is defending it and the complete lack of
Donald Trump ever I mean he you know
earlier I jokingly said Trump apologized
for tweeting fake news he just never he
doesn't take responsibility for anything
he doesn't take responsibility for the
unnecessary coronavirus deaths which are
not the full hundred thousand of course
right I mean but but some fraction
certainly would have been avoided up to
sixty percent according to a recent
study had Trump acted earlier he doesn't
take responsibility for lack of testing
he doesn't just say you know what it was
over the line to go after Joe
Scarborough in the son founded way it
did bring unnecessary pain to the family
of the victim lorica Slough he will
never do it he will never do it and if
you're holding your breath waiting for
him to do it you will soon die from from
asphyxiation because he's simply not
going to do it okay it disgusts me that
at this stage of the game I have to do
this story today but I have to do this
story today it appears that multiple
states are pick your poison having
issues lying falsifying distorting
coronavirus testing case and or death
numbers and there is no doubt that this
is affecting our understanding of how
effectively we are dealing with
coronavirus in the United States in a
bunch of different parts and the reason
why this is just sickening is last week
I came to you and I said listen guys I
don't know why but there are some closed
states states that have been shut down
for months that are doing really no
better than some states that have opened
wouldn't it be amazing if states really
could reopen without seeing spikes maybe
that's possible except now with all of
these allegations of bogus numbers and
dishonest numbers and suppression of
numbers it becomes a lot more difficult
to know what's really going on so here's
the deal and some of these individual
components we've already talked about in
the past one example was Georgia Georgia
had reopened really early started on I
believe it was April 20
forth their numbers didn't really look
too bad they used that data to justify
continuing to reopen other states said
look at what's going on in Georgia we
can justify reopening Georgia officials
now admit that they had processing
errors processing errors which made it
look like infections were declining when
they actually were not that data that
three times had so-called errors was
what they used to justify reopening more
and more and more when in reality the
numbers were far worse than they were
publicizing that's Georgia Florida
Florida I already told you about the
situation where cause of death was being
suppressed for a while which was
artificially holding down coronavirus
deaths I told you last week about this
data modeler sort of tech person who was
pushed out / fired we still don't have
the full explanation after she said I'm
not going to falsify data which was what
she was allegedly told to do that's
Florida Arizona Arizona has become one
of the most open States and they have
also become one of the fastest spiking
states on a percentage basis they cut
off a team of Health Service experts who
were modeling the state data it wasn't
looking great instead Arizona decided
the governor Republican governor said
hey you know what let's use the federal
government modeling data which of course
is much more optimistic and much more
easily usable to justify reopening
although it is not reflective of what is
actually going on in Arizona then we
have this other story where the CDC and
11 different states have been sometimes
combining when they report tests they're
combining infection and antibody tests
which dramatically increases the testing
rate on paper reduces the positive rate
on paper it doesn't actually reflect how
many people are catching the virus and
how many active infections there are
it's absolutely insane that this has
been done and this includes Colorado
Delaware Georgia Maine Mississippi
Missouri New Hampshire Pennsylvania
Texas Vermont and Virginia all mixing
infection and anti-b
tests at one point in their reporting
some of the states have since fixed this
that includes places like Vermont and
Virginia unclear which other states have
fixed this in which other states
continue to do this when we have a
situation like in Pennsylvania we are
also dramatically under counting what
the severity of the widespread infection
is because Pennsylvania is not providing
full data on cases and deaths from
nursing homes nursing homes nationally
have been huge hotspots of infection in
Massachusetts at one point 50 or 60
percent of the deaths were in nursing
homes
imagine if Massachusetts said yeah we'll
report data except from nursing homes
you'd think the outbreak was only half
as bad Nebraska at one point told meat
packing plants you don't have to report
your cases and the governor wrote it off
and said well that's a business decision
now it's a public health decision and
it's one that is propagandizing the
premature opening of states so we've
sunk lower than low we are doing in bits
and pieces what Trump slams China for
doing not telling the truth about cases
and deaths and it's happening right here
all Americans should be outraged period
this borders China aside this borders on
the totalitarian type rewriting a
reality type nonsense that we claim to
be opposed to we now simply cannot
really believe that we are doing better
or that some states are doing better
because we're not getting accurate
information it is being suppressed to
justify reopening in many states how
dare we say how dare China cover up the
numbers when we're doing the exact same
thing and they do not care we continue
to see protests without masks we
continue to see a lack of social
distancing we continue to see full bars
and restaurants often immediately within
30 minutes of states lifting some
elements of the stay at home orders this
is a time where you know listen
Massachusetts has not been perfect
there's no doubt Charlie Baker was not
the fastest but he was much faster than
a lot of other states this is a place
where
you know when I look at the data here in
Massachusetts number one I can
reasonably trust the data there is
transparency about nursing home deaths
there's transparency about testing
numbers the curve looks good we have now
been under a hundred deaths for a whole
bunch of days or you know 95 percent of
a whole bunch of days the curve is
reversing testing is being ramped up
this is one of those times where I am
genuinely glad to live in a state that
is at least somewhat tethered to truth
and reality it's not been perfect it's
certainly not been perfect but what is
happening in some of these states is
borderline criminal in the sense that it
is distorting it is public information
government state government releasing
information that is wrong to justify
policies and actions that lead to more
people in the hospital more people in
ICUs and more people dying and you know
all of these dishonest players Trump at
the top but people at the state level
people at local levels they all must
suffer the consequences for their
participation in this we're going to
keep covering this on Instagram at David
Pakman show I did something funny I
posted a picture of me pre quarantine
and now to my Instagram David Pakman I
barely recognize pre quarantine me it's
shocking how much my physical appearance
has changed during the quarantine check
it out at David Pakman we'll take a
quick break and we have so much more
coming up for you okay I want to get
ahead of what is going to be a barrage
of absolute BS garbage math this is what
I'm calling a garbage math you are going
to be hit left and right by garbage math
over the next few months and the goal of
the garbage math will be for you to
think that Donald Trump deserves to be
re-elected and we've already been
starting to see some of what I'm calling
garbage math with coronavirus for a
while so for example when Trump ists
talked about the total number of tests
that have been done in the United States
that's garbage math it doesn't tell us
very much tests per day are what matter
tests per capita or what matter we're
four months into this thing right
the cumulative number of tests that have
been done tell us very very little
another example over the last couple of
months we've seen such economic
destruction that it now opens the door
to wild meaningless claims about growth
rates in certain industries which are
already being touted as huge victories
now I want to give you a really specific
example there's been this headline
floating around air travel surges air
travel and bookings surged a hundred and
twenty percent the New York Times
actually wrote about this when this
started being touted so understand when
coronavirus hit air travel dropped by
one estimate ninety six percent
so when you say air travel surges a
hundred and twenty percent it has surged
a hundred and twenty percent or roughly
doubled from almost zero okay so
imagining that air travel is going well
completely ignores just basic math let's
look at some numbers if you start with
what would be one hundred percent right
like full air travel and you then
experience a 96 percent decrease to air
travel you end up with four percent of
the air travel you started with you
start with something you take away 96
percent you're left with four percent if
you then increase air travel by a
hundred and twenty percent air travel is
still down 91 percent from where it was
this is just a common function of how
percentages and growth rates work if you
lose 50 percent of something you need to
gain 100 percent to get back to where
you were if I have $100 in stock and
that stock loses 50% of its value my
hundred dollars is now worth $50 to get
back to $100 I need that 50 bucks to
increase 100 percent and this is the
crux of a ton of the disinformation
propaganda propaganda garbage math that
you are going to be hit with over the
next few months as the recovery
hopefully starts to happen depending on
how deadly coronavirus remains and how
bad wave 2 is you are going to see a lot
of this stuff I'll give you some other
examples jobs have so imploded
that they will start using job growth
numbers that will be meaningless because
of the base numbers that are being used
understand that we lost more than 20% of
our workforce so far we might recover 5%
of the current workforce and they will
say hey we're already a quarter of the
way back that's not how growth rates
work if you lose 20% of the workforce
and then you gain back 5% of that
reduced number you're only gaining 19%
of what you lost
not 25 so understand how these growth
rates work the one that will really be
weaponized is probably going to be GDP
we in all likelihood are going to see
historic GDP lost numbers for the second
quarter in the United States we're not
going to get those numbers until
sometime in August most likely so
normally the numbers would be for
example like o GD P and Q 2 went up
point five percent usually you annualize
that so 0.5% over four quarters would be
like on track for two percent GDP growth
for the year okay the decline in the
second quarter is going to be massive it
could be ten percent could be twelve
percent could be 25 percent imagine it's
15 percent if you annualize that fifteen
percent one quarter loss it would be
like sixty percent for the year it's not
going to really tell us much because in
all likelihood in the third quarter if
things go as are sort of expected we're
going to start to see a recovery and
remember that recovery in GDP would only
be a fraction of what was lost in the
second quarter the headlines and Trump
and others are going to say for example
imagine that we lose fifteen percent in
q2 and gain five percent in q3 relative
to those previous numbers the trumpet
will say oh my god five percent in a
quarter we're on track for twenty
percent GDP growth if you annualize it
even China doesn't grow 20
percent in a year and of course that
would be wrong because we will have just
suffered one of the if not the greatest
GDP loss in the merit in American
history and there would be no reason to
annualize third quarter GDP growth if we
have it given that it is a year with
massive ups and downs so the the concern
I have is that the timing of that could
be very very pernicious we are likely to
learn the q3 GDP numbers at the end of
October that is days before the
presidential election and it is going to
present the perfect opportunity for
Donald Trump to do what will essentially
be like 96 hours of propaganda confusing
people about q3 GDP numbers to justify
his reelection and it may work I'm
trying to stay ahead of it
I don't want you to fall for the garbage
math and the reason why it's important
to understand is that this is one would
there's a couple different things first
of all you don't want to get tricked by
bad math we all want to have basic math
and statistics understanding but number
two policymakers are going to be using
bad data to justify the policies that
they would be advocating for anyway and
pretending like it's where the facts are
taking us when the reality is they'd be
advocating for the same policies no
matter what and they'd be advocating for
the re-election of Donald Trump no
matter what they will claim victory they
will claim mission accomplished
understand growth rates understand
percentages don't fall for the garbage
math make sure you're following me on
Twitter let me know what other fuzzy
math you were seeing for lack of a
better term and remember that you can
get the daily David Pakman show audio
podcast for free on iTunes stitcher
google play podcasts all of your
favorite podcasting platforms sign up
free and get the daily podcast